welcome to another dr sadler philosophy
forum i have a good friend and colleague
and also fellow vet and that you'll see
why that's important as we talk about
this caleb on with me who's uh
stepped in graciously at last minute to
make this possible and today we're going
to talk about um issues surrounding
militarization of police here in the
united states and there's been a lot of
discussion about this particularly
prompted by
by ferguson which was kind of a catalyst
i think for that and that's a really
good thing in my view and i think in
caleb's view as well
but you know we're talking about trends
that have been going on
for quite some time and have intensified
in the last 10 years
so
there's a lot to say about this we're
not gonna you know solve the issue in
any
major sense
today but there's there's a lot of um
there's a lot of
related connected big picture issues
that i think
moral philosophy and political
philosophy is particularly good at
pointing out so that's part of what we
want to talk about today as usual we're
going to be taking
questions comments if you want to use
the question and answer app that's one
really good way to do it um since we're
just going back and forth i'm not going
to be looking at the youtube feed so if
you write questions there i might not
see them until afterwards best to use
the q a app in google plus so i'm going
to sort of turn the floor over to to
caleb to talk a little bit about about
the issue and the issues
because he's he's done some some actual
research about this going you know far
beyond what i've done so
no further ado caleb
well thanks for having me again uh
really enjoyable last time i'm looking
forward to
tonight's uh discussion um
yeah i mean the topic of police
militarization i think is
uh
is a very important topic but also a
topic that's really important for
uh philosophical
thought um which i think that you know
often maybe you know people would think
well okay this is kind of a you know
practical issue or political issue
um but i think it really goes to the
core of how we think about um
some of the key concepts that figure
into political philosophy you know
particularly like the idea of the state
and um
you know there there's a there's a sense
in which
a dominant strand of
uh
philosophical theorizing
would again kind of think about you know
uh you know
rawls as representative you know really
kind of kantian political philosophy but
try to just think about a lot of these
issues uh
you know
uh abstractly you know let's think about
you know the ideal uh you know
uh state or you know however you want to
kind of view it i mean there's a lot of
different um you know bralesses behind
the bale of ignorance there's different
different ways of kind of talking about
this but it shares this sense in which
um
political philosophy should be done
primarily um or should at least be
initiated um abstractly say in the
classroom or in the
you know conference hall you know in
lecture hall not um dealing with kind of
real issues that are affecting people
i actually you know i think if you can
even go back to to uh to aristotle
and um and his kind of beef with plato
one of the key
um issues you know he he criticized the
idea of the good in the first book of
the ethics
and then in the second book of the
politics you know he's criticizing the
idea of kind of an abstract
um
you know the republic right abstract
kind of uh
uh political theory and um
i i think that um when we're thinking
about um
you know
questions of you know uh political
philosophy you know whether it's you
know
uh the the extent of the state or the
purpose of the state or you know
questions of justice
um
we need to first look at
issues like police militarization you
know um because i think that especially
you know this question of police
militarization this is where the power
the power of the state
is manifest in daily the daily life
of you know your average citizen you
know so anyways it's kind of an intro
this is why i think it's kind of a
really important topic
yeah
i i agree i think that a lot of our
theorizing needs to be done from the
vantage point of actually you know some
some place where there's traction
um
because you know how do we get
interested in these these issues of
abstract justice who ought to rule it's
usually because
we've got problems
real problems and the social media has
been particularly good for letting us
see them in a much more timely way in a
perhaps more systematic way
and then we you know we have to figure
out what we're going to do given this
messed up situation aristotle i i kind
of like for this as well you know in the
politics he um
i think it's in book four
he's looking at is any of the current
existing greek states
back in ancient greece are any of them
particularly good and he says no not any
of them they're all they're all screwed
up in one way or another
and that doesn't hold him back from
saying well here's how we ought to
analyze things and here's how we can
make things
better
um so instead of beginning from you know
like the ideal blueprint
and then saying how can we how can we
trickle that down to where we actually
live
it's it's more like well here's where
here's the the mess we're stuck in
now let's think our way
towards some better uh solution
how can we make it yeah incremental
improvement i think it's much easier to
uh think about realistic solutions
and to think about ideal you know
concepts or constructs um from you know
again the problem you can it's much
easier to think about well how can we
make this situation a little bit better
you know as opposed to what would be the
best you know what's the best uh
relationship between
you know the the government the state
and the police force and the people you
know and um
um
you know
it would be worthwhile to uh
um you know just say a little bit more
about you know what we mean by police
militarization you know i mean
um
uh
you know i mean one of the you know one
of the main things of course has been
the the proliferation of
military-grade equipment basically by
police departments and it's been you
know intentionally uh
a perpetuator or you know the federal
government has pushed
um surplus military equipment
to police forces all around the country
uh here in here in baton rouge we have a
uh
an armored vehicle that i think was in
iraq that's now uh
protecting the streets or i i think they
say on their website the company's
website that will be assaulting the
streets of baton rouge you know
um and uh
you know the other is the you know the
development of
development and you know proliferation
of swat teams you know when they
initially
developed
in los angeles you know in response to
these riots and
um
you know it was presented as well this
is something you know in the case of
these dire situations where you know
there's a need for
um
you know these kind of advanced
special weapons and tactics teams you
know
um but now
swat teams um
you know they're making they're making
uh
just
an incredible amount of raids
uh i'm trying to remember the exact uh
you know increase but i think it's gone
to something to where they're making
like you know um
we're talking like hundreds of raids a
week you know from where you went from
you know
again you know there's a riot this is a
you know uh you know very rare situation
you know okay well we need to have this
team for you know to now they're serving
you know primarily for non-violent
crimes you know you're having swat teams
breaking in
uh
no knock raids or even if they do a
the supreme court essentially has
a la have said that you need to give
basically 10 seconds for a knock so you
know you sort of knock with the
battering ram
and then you know you can
punch the door
down you know and um
uh
you know so i mean um using military
tactics for non-violent crimes um
um
you also i think another issue that
needs to be considered um which is
often maybe separated from but really
the idea of like just increased police
surveillance we have used
are using um
uh they call them stingrays is one one
um a stingray
technology to track cell phones you know
and uh there's it's really unclear um
to what degree this is being used by
police forces i mean there have been
reports around the country uh
some sheriff's departments are basically
unwilling to
share
you know information about really
without a court order they won't admit
whether they're using these things and
um again it's this process where
you know there's a there's kind of uh
you have the military contractors the
federal government
and you know local buyers who are able
to kind of
um they're able to push this equipment
down um and so i mean
i think that uh
i think you know maybe
those three the tactics
the uh or i would probably include a
fourth one but say tactics military
equipment surveillance and then uh
federalization you know that they're
increasingly
the marshals the fbi
um dea other federal agencies are
um intertwined with these local police
forces and again it's not clear whether
who's calling the shots
where the power you know
it's not clear
to what degree the police force are
really responsive to the local community
really once it's they become federalized
you know
um there's an interesting economic um
sort of trade-off too because you know i
think about swat teams if you if you put
together a swat team
there you've got an asset that you don't
want just sitting around because it's
it's expensive all that training the you
know maintenance equipment you want to
see it in action
um
so there's there's you know once you
actually invest in in that there's
there's an incentive to use it and then
you know with the
surplus equipment
you had the surplus equipment and the
department of homeland security grants
to to
police departments most of them you know
say
look this equipment's going to get
trashed anyway it may as well be us that
have it um the money's there for the
taking if we don't apply for it somebody
else will so there's there's that kind
of thing going on and there are there
are some departments that actually you
know did deliberately turn down
these these things but i i imagine that
there's a lot of pressure
um
from coming from a lot of different you
know places
to to take the money and buy the
equipment and now you've now you've got
more assets that if they're just sitting
there they're not doing you any good
yeah and the other the other i mean to
add to that you know there's a there's
an economic incentive
um
you know as far as getting getting
grants you know if you're so
participating in like dea programs to
where you're going to increase the
number of
of drug busts let's say some of these
programs you know basically incentivize
these kind of
uh
swat
uh swat raids on low-level dealers you
know people who really non-violent
because
um
if you're if you know if you're going to
be eligible for increased funding based
on the number of bucks
well you want to go for all the small
fish not the big guy you know
and so you know there's some there's
some misguided kind of incentives here
that sort of
seem to distort uh
you know
just distort the system you know and so
um i mean there's really no reason for
busting
joe blow who's you know
selling marijuana here when you you know
um
you know small amounts you know when you
can you know make the effort to go after
the dealer because you know somebody
else is just going to step in i mean as
soon as soon as you make these arrests
you know i mean
there's there's no shortage of people
who are willing to to make a little bit
especially in hard economic times to
make a little bit of money you know
um and so it's really incentivizing
ineffective policing really you know
where you're seeing these really violent
tactics against people who are
that aren't very violent you know
so let me ask you a really pointed
question
and we'll you know let's look at that
ferguson there we've got an issue
of crowd control and you know the
policing that's going on
is pretty much just you know riot lines
and and sort of you know urban
pacification essentially
now
that's that's just sort of a piece of
the picture and that's not something
that i think
when people are militarizing police
they're thinking yeah that's exactly the
sort of thing you want to have it's sort
of a
natural consequence of it it sounds like
you know
why did why did police militarize well
there were incentives for them to do
that they they felt like um
this would help them more drug raids
this would help them deal with um
other types of of crime going on
and now it it spills over and becomes
very easy for police departments to just
you know sort of roll that mentality
through
and turn a place like ferguson into
you know territory to occupy
is that
that do you think that's an accurate way
to put it
yeah oh i mean i i think that um
i think yeah i think i mean
very much so i mean i think that
um
you know you've already had i mean in
the background is the issue of racism
you know in many police departments you
know certainly not all of them but
there's been many cases where
um there's some pretty clear
issues of race
some of the major departments around the
country and so there's already a sense
in which
um
the
police department's sort of enforcing
the
uh
the will of the social and economic
elite and so there's always there's
already a sense of kind of an occupation
and i think um you know there's most
likely you know i mean i mean definitely
there's been some you know abatement of
some issues of racism um
supreme court and and the courts have
kind of done some things even
even in here in louisiana there were
some issues that were kind of um
under the court supervision
but um
i think that uh you still have
um a real sense in which
uh
the police you know primarily protect
you know property you know i mean it's
you know that and so people own a lot of
property
um
in a certain sense the police kind of
work for them more than they do for
people who i mean they certainly protect
people's lives and other things but um
so i think that you know that it
contributes to that divide and then when
you bring in
military equipment um
it becomes
indistinguishable from you know
occupations like in
in iraq you know in baghdad you know i
mean it looks very similar to what's
going on there you know you have a uh
you know seemingly uh you know a
militarized group who doesn't really
have much to do with the community where
they're enforcing
laws um primarily
um
you know put in place by people who
don't have much to do with the community
you know so i mean you know i think it
plays on kind of previous class and
racial divisions you know and
militarization just kind of
um
kicks that you know into a further you
know kind of uh
you know makes it much worse you know
yeah
i've seen a lot of
that are sort of opposing militarization
police tactics directly to community
policing and saying if you're going to
do this you can't do this
and it's interesting because los angeles
appears to lower their crime by
reemphasizing community policing which
they seem to have been against for quite
a while
but you know with community policing
here's where we start getting you know
back into the political philosophy
what's really essential about that
there's a sense uh
the
the protectors of the community or the
enforcers of order have to have
a relationship with the people
who they're
they're policing there has to be you
know if we want to think about this kind
of hegelian terms some mutual
recognition there you're you're a person
you're a stakeholder i am to not just
i'm here to tell you what to do or to
put you into the system or to
you know lock you up
um
that sort of uh
mentality
um
let me ask you i'm gonna sort of steer
it a different way as well
and i want to ask you about this
specifically as as being a vet
um
so one of the things that i came across
in a new york times article was that
in indianapolis suburbs officers said
they needed a mine resistant vehicle to
protect against a
possible attack by veterans returning
from war there's this worry that
you know we've been at war for
over a decade we've had a lot of young
men and women who aren't particularly
well treated when they get back
particularly by the va
and they've got all this experience um
you know it seems like police
departments
instead of just you know
they'd seem like some of these people
would be the ones you'd want to
incorporate into the police departments
because they actually know how to handle
weapons you know carefully
um
police departments are seeing them as a
potential threat at the same time
so i'd like to get your reaction to that
but at the same time is there something
in you i know there is in me is that
when i see
people who aren't
military
being given all the equipment of
military and acting like their military
there's something in me that gets gets
upset that gets angry at seeing that
like they're
they don't belong there you know i i
have to admit too and this is a terrible
thing to say but when i back when i was
in we had that sort of attitude towards
the national guardsman event but things
are really different
you know a lot of national guards have a
lot of experience because they've you
know served over in iraq or afghanistan
um so so those two questions the
you know
reaction to police department seeing
veterans as an actual threat and then as
a reason why they need to be militarized
and then
is there something
are my feelings completely off in this
or is this a sort of you know
representative reaction to seeing police
militarization
uh yeah absolutely so i'll answer the
the second one first um
i uh
there was actually a
raid a series of raids
um
i think two years ago before the
sheriff's election and the
parish not counting i'm in louisiana we
have parishes but he was the sheriff um
was retiring and there was the first
deputy was kind of running against ever
several other people it was kind of a
heated race
and um
he uh
so you know of course he was the first
deputy who had a lot of you know
influence and he was on the force
already so
uh the neither a couple nights before
the um
election i think it was the night before
they they went on these uh
uh you know
setting that out you know they're going
to catch all these drug dealers you know
they're going out busting
and
they film uh this swat rate of a house
and
uh there's you know there's about four
deputies kind of lined up
and they throw flash bang grenades at
the door
the doors shut they throw them at the
door they of course they go off when
they hit the door
and they don't really do anything
because there's nobody there to be
stunned by the flash and then they kick
the door in and go in and you know
arrest this guy who is i think selling
uh oxycontin or something you know i
mean not
and uh you know so you know watching
this you know and it's like these guys
you know
they appear not to know what they're
doing because the flashbang grenade is
used you know
to stun somebody you know it's bright
it's loud throwing against a door
before you kick it in
is just pointless you know and so you
know
i mean you know when i was uh
you know in the military i mean um i i
did i shot mortars and um
usually there's you know a much smaller
number of
mortar men we call you know as we call
ourselves you know compared to the
regular infantrymen so we were always
kind of set apart and so we we pride
ourselves on kind of professionalism you
know that we were um we had to be better
than you know other people we had to
make sure that we
you know we had everything together
because we would stand out if we you
know we weren't in shape if we couldn't
obviously couldn't do our job or any of
these kind of things
and you know we trained constantly and
so i i am a little skeptical of
um
many swat teams because they're
typically in in the smaller departments
they're part-time swat teams so they're
going to do some training but most of
their job is going to be you know
patrolling whatever you know doing other
things and i'm just not sure that you
can really do part-time swat you know
to use military equipment and to do
military tactics it takes a lot of
training and constant training and so
yeah i mean i feel the same way i i i i
there's
you know you can see these videos on
youtube a swat team you know shooting
and doing you know uh and it's just
something about it kind of rubs me raw
you know it just
um
you know it just doesn't it seems like
it's like
um
you know we're just we're playing with
we're playing with guns basically
you know i mean um you know i'm sure
it's not the case in all departments but
um i think that there is a danger of
that whenever you give like some
sophisticated equipment to people who
just don't have a lot of training you
know um
so uh you know for the other question
about veterans um you know i think that
that really goes back to the same issue
with with race though i think that um
uh and and i kind of think of it in
terms of uh
mcintyre's uh practice institution kind
of framework because i think that uh
you know um when he thinks in terms of
like a practice especially you know
politics is a practice but really any
practice
one of the key ideas is the idea of sort
of uh you know the cooperative activity
you know and so the shared standards by
by which you can kind of
um you know
you can measure your actions you can
kind of uh deliberate about things you
can kind of discuss you know in terms of
again shared standards um much in common
i think with a kind of hegelian you know
the notion of mutual recognition and why
that's important um but i think that um
so i think of these small towns and we
think of you know uh local politics you
know as a practice let's say and you
know that you have this kind of
institutional framework supported by the
police um
well i think that you know in today's
situation
you really don't have very much uh very
many uh you know
uh flourishing kind of local political
communities you know you increasingly uh
you know influenced by uh or dominated
by you know uh the need to
uh
you know bring corporations in so you
have you know you have these uh towns
that will basically you know
uh
you know
sell to the lowest better you know give
tax breaks or whatever you know
increasingly you know there's not an
ability to think about a kind of shared
community and what it means to kind of
live in that community
the same with you know the federal
government you know funding from the
federal government really
controls much of the policies that local
communities can do and you know they
want to get funding and um
so i think that um
veterans come home to
um
you know a situation where yeah like you
said there
they've been you know not um there's not
much
uh there's not very much you know
treatment available with the va and
their promise different thing
um but i think even more you know your
your
you return to a community that is very
much um fragmented
and
uh
you know ultimately kind of
individualistic you know in many ways
although you know um you know these
there's these patriotic ideals that you
know
um but i think that you don't really
find that reality you know
uh when you return so i think that um
you know
it's easy for
um you know veterans to be you know
you know stay unhappy or um but on the
other hand i think that you know um
there's really no evidence to say that
like veterans are somehow a more
dangerous group than any other you know
group that's out there you know i mean
we're not finding you know attacks by
veterans or you know
um
so in that sense i think it's kind of
ridiculous you know
yeah
so
let's talk about a few other things and
we'll start addressing some of the
questions i see we're already getting
some
um
let's look at some of the the big
political
theory kinds of questions that come up
um you know one of the things that this
suggests immediately is the who guards
the guardians
question from that's always posed with
you know plato's republic
uh
and you know do we need to differentiate
between
this doesn't happen in plato's republic
because it's a very different kind of
thing but um we have a long tradition
here in the united states of keeping
policing and military very separate not
not something that's done in some other
countries where the military
are often you know deeply involved in
the police are essentially paramilitary
um
one of the issues that keeps arising
is
how do how do we actually get any sort
of
first you know oversight
and then some sort of
control over these these police
departments there's you know an entire
patchwork
of local municipal police departments
sheriffs
uh departments you know it's different
too like down down by you guys the
sheriffs have a lot more power than they
do up here up here is the state troopers
of course
um
and then you know all these like you
said this patchwork of federal agencies
how do we actually how do we guard the
guardians that would be the the key
question you know
um yeah you know i i mean i think that
an american situation
uh
i think a lot more thought needs to go
into what it means
to uh
you know
what what military are and what i mean
you know
what military you know i mean
the the
the fbi let's say the dea
the marshals i mean these are you know
essentially
you know
uh you know non-military
um you know agencies but
you know again increasingly it becomes
difficult to
really make that claim
um they're using military equipment and
military tactics um
but also in many cases they've actually
done operations in
uh you know uh afghanistan or iraq
yeah you have
dea
fbi um and i think marshalls um
definitely dea and fbi um have done
operations with
with the military and you know and so
many of these people are kind of
rotating
you know at least you know some are
rotating back and forth or from military
to kind of civilian so i mean you know
um
i think that it's really been a way to
get around
um
you know uh
that you know the the the idea that the
military can't
you know uh
perform police uh action
um
and again i think it's a way of
manifesting state power you know um
i you know i think that you know in the
the u.s um
the
you know the ideal again it's kind of
federalist ideal it's kind of gradually
kind of eroded away and you know for
different reasons and
you know um
not not all of them kind of bad i guess
you could say you know much how to do
the civil war and things like that but i
think that you know if you have these
increasingly well-funded
you know so-called police agencies on
the federal level um
you know
the the opportunity for having you know
anything like community policing
you know um
it basically shifts power very you know
a lot of power to the federal government
and um
you know
you have you know little opportunity for
having a kind of police force that's
responsive to the needs and
you know the the kind of goods that are
kind of potentially important to the
people they're policing you know uh
it seems like that's not just an issue
with with you know
sort of not devolving but you know great
setting up the power of the up the chain
of the federal government but but also
it is an issue still at the local level
like one of the problems with ferguson
was that you know like a lot of police
departments
most of the police officers who are
patrolling the streets don't actually
reside in the community so they don't
have a stake there they don't um
they don't you know it lends itself very
much to us versus them mentality both on
their part and on the part of the
residence
and even you know even when other bodies
were brought in you know state troopers
come in to try to restore order after
the local police can't
are going overboard doing crazy stuff
those troopers weren't able to do it
themselves and then you know eventually
it
managed to
get under control but um there was it
was more matter it wasn't a matter of
you know
federal agencies haven't screwed things
up it was the locals and so it's like a
two-pronged kind of thing
yeah no i think that's a really good
point i mean i i think
yeah i mean again i think it's kind of
symptomatic of the kind of broken
local political culture and lack of you
know real
um
and you know i mean that that there's
probably a lot of kind of reasons behind
it um i mean i always think of you know
uh you know chuckville's kind of
townships is these ideals you know for
um
you know for for american kind of
democracy you know again we kind of now
now they think in terms of you know
democracy as being really at the
national level
um but he really saw that you know
without a vibrant local democracy
you know um
you really couldn't really hope to have
a
a a good national government i think
that um
you know there's been a lot of talk
about cities the importance of cities uh
and some books have been published
recently but i think that you know
looking back to
how can we make
local communities
responsive to people give giving voice
to to citizens i mean
it's not realistic to think of voting
you know once every four years or you
know whatever depending on you know uh
you know congressional elections and
voting a few times you know
um you know in a national election is
actually giving a meaningful voice
um
so i mean
i think that you know unless you can
unless you can make these communities
more responsive and more particularly um
the people who have power are going to
use the police to
uh
you know
to maintain order or to make you know
you're going to have these situations
where you have kind of police as an
occupying force you know i'm wondering
in part whether in a lot of cases you
know we
look at this analysis of sort of the
elites and then the police is being kind
of like the middleman and then there's
uh
you know populous
it seems like in a lot of these cases
these police departments
are so to speak going global they're
they're becoming their own entities
um great example of that is um
asset forfeitures you know where instead
of like going into the city coffers it
goes right back into the department so
there's an incentive to let's let's step
up the you know the forfeitures so we
can we can through our show and then it
seems like in a lot of cases the at
least the political authorities
um don't have an awfully good idea about
what these police departments are
actually up to until something like
ferguson happens and then suddenly
they're you know there's a big surprise
oh look look you know
they've been militarized as if somehow
it just sort of happened
without them you know paying close
attention to it right yeah um
i wonder if there is you know if we
can't talk about
a sort of you know middle level
culture of militarization across these
police departments
where the police are becoming
through this
more and more independent of political
authority and more and more just their
own
yeah i think that that's i mean i think
that i mean you mentioned like you know
sheriff's departments here i mean
you know they have a lot of power and
sheriff's association
and you know i would guess in different
ways you know um
police departments are able to kind of
you know
kind of gather power and um
yeah i mean you know again i think it's
i still think you know much of this is
kind of um
symptomatic of kind of
essentially oligarchy at the national
level
and just kind of broken
you know
broken political structures kind of at
the local level that are mostly uh in
response to there are as a result of
that
um
you know i mean again i think we should
see this all together you know we have
these uh
uh citizen united case right and then
you have this uh just recently i think
the senate refused to
uh
they shot down a bill that was gonna
kind of address that and you know um
so i think that you know
the um
there's less and less kind of meaningful
uh you know voice politicians are able
to or have to kind of uh seek out the
money you know from wherever they can
and kind of
um and i think that yeah i mean there's
no real
uh
there's no real thought of kind of
regulating you know
you know can we have a discussion about
what what is our fleet force for
you know and um
you know
do you think that's hurting in part by
the fact that our police forces are so
localized
you know i mean we can have we can have
a town hall meeting and discuss what the
local police force is doing or you know
we can pick it outside of albany about
what the state troopers are doing
but um
i don't have any you know i don't have
any stake or control over what's going
on
you know the next town over
or in new jersey or down by you guys in
louisiana you know
so
how do we you know
we can have sort of a national discourse
about police militarization but in order
to change things
you would have to change at all these
different uh
points
what do you think is reported
well i mean you know much much would be
you know if the federal government would
would not incentivize
and not pay you know incentivize and pay
for militarization i mean much would
much would change um
yeah i mean you know i
i think that um
you know i i think that you know that
it's easy to think in terms of like
these militarized police forces and you
know problems but it would probably be
worthwhile to look at you know
communities where this works well you
know what you know what goes on and you
know i don't know any examples i mean
particularly you know why you know that
i could kind of point you and say this
is kind of but i think that i'm sure
that there are situations where
you know um and so i mean
i i guess the problem is it seems at a
national level
you know um
again discourse is kind of controlled by
the media and
um
it was really interesting that this kind
of discussion of police militarization
came up and lasted for about a week and
then um isis came on
i mean it was almost as you know as if
it's like
all right now you guys need to start
talking about something that'll get
people you know afraid i mean
immediately they're talking about eye
cases and threats and so i should have
been
uh active for have been active for quite
a while you know but it was sort of all
of a sudden you know there was um
it just it's very hard to have
yeah to have kind of
coherent discussions you know with all
the talking heads and all the you know i
mean um
you know
the question of again voice you know i
mean i think it's best done at the local
level like i think that there's a need
to kind of just figure out well
you know how can we make
departments
a little bit more responsive to you know
how we make local governments and and
you know including police departments
uh you know a little bit more responsive
to kind of people you know and um
again there are some good cases i think
i mentioned about like uh racism i think
there's been some you know measures to
kind of um
tear down some of the kind of racial
divide and things like that and you
might look to how is that done to kind
of
see where you you know improve
let's take some uh some of the questions
that we've got um coming in from viewers
so
um
one of them brought up this is thomas
field he's actually got a
quotation from plato's republic
um
it's about the watchdogs keep watch dogs
who from want of discipline or hunger or
some evil habit or other would turn on
the sheep and worry them and behave not
like dogs but wolves
that that does sound very much like a
you know prescient description of
what um
what goes on in some of these cases that
they're you know
the police are there they're supposed to
be protecting and serving that's the
motto
and you know you look at the old um
ethics discussions and originally
setting up police forces
they were supposed to be
um
having the local people respect them on
the basis for example of their
impartiality
the fact that they're not gonna go
beyond the power that they're supposed
to have
and so you know you're opposed to this
this problem what do you do once the
police go go wild
that does seem to be the the central
issue
how do you reign them in once they've
actually gotten a taste for
for uh
let's say blood here maybe the kind of
power
that
militarization brings about
yeah i mean i think that you know
there's again there's different people
who are kind of dealing it depends on
you know
um again i think a lot of it goes to the
you know racial divide and really in a
lot of african-american
communities i think is or we see you
know stronger police presence and you
know and and um
uh so i think in areas where you don't
have that and i mean it's certainly
other areas but you know i mean i think
that um you know so in areas where you
don't have that um i think it's easy you
know for people who hear discussion of
police militarization say well
you know yeah i want the police to go
you know
uh you know use whatever they need to
stop crime you know like they're not you
know it's almost like that you know the
whole you know well the first they came
for so and so you know then they came
for you know um
and so i think that um
part of the part of the issue is on a
local level you know um building
coalitions
um
with of different kind of stakeholders
in in a local in the city or a local
community you know and um raising
awareness of um
of these issues and again i almost think
it's not you know almost not in terms of
like
you know
even even like an abstract notion like
police militarization but you know for
instance
in the equation like a armored person we
need an armored personnel carrier you
know why do we need you know having
having these you know sheriffs or or
whoever police chiefs justify
you know and really working to um
i mean it seems to me that that's the
only hope of you know it's going to be a
kind of a incremental level on a local
incremental level because
um
you know i
there's a lot of there's a lot of money
at stake in these pro federal programs
and i don't know that it's going to be
realistic to kind of
uh you know eliminate the fema the uh
dhs grants and the yeah
you know i mean that's the other side
right contractors have a huge market
opened up
because now they're able to sell not
only i mean because some of it is
surplus equipment but they've also been
able to sell if you have a militarized
force well they're going to want to buy
other things and they've been able to
sell a lot of things
that before they were only selling to
the military and
you know again lobby their their
lobbying there's a lot of pressure so i
i anyway i think i i kind of typically
go back to local level i think that
in a place like baton rouge it probably
could be possible to have kind of
somewhat of a discussion of you know
you know this question you know do we
need you know what's going on with these
things and i have some obstacles you
know but i think that um
yeah that's that's the best way i mean i
you know
getting people who don't think it's
their problem to realize you know why it
is a problem
yeah that's probably
one of the most important components and
maybe um
you know one of the things we have to
think about with this is why why do
people sometimes say well look you know
let the police do whatever they need to
do um those criminals over there you
know they're they've got it coming to
them in part it's because they don't
have any direct experience with
you know what what's actually going on
they don't they don't see the
effects on
the local population
or
you know collateral damage or anything
like that except that you know perhaps
and
it's tough to think about how one would
actually
promote
that that kind of direct experience
um
you know social media offers
some things but it's almost always
sensationalized this guy got shot
there's the video
and then people weigh in and great
outrage but not a lot seems to get done
so there does seem to be some some need
to think about how to like you said
raise awareness
um how how precisely to do that we know
that's the end now we have to think of
the appropriate means
for that
let's take another uh set of questions
this is from uh
my friend leandra lima
and he's asking a
fast case worst case kind of scenario
thing what is your optimistic outlook of
this growth in power through
federalization and militarization and
what's the pessimistic problem
so which do you want to start with bad
news or
good potential good groups
uh
i i'll start with the optimistic first
yeah
um
i uh you know i could
uh
to think of myself as kind of at least
being um
hopeful if not optimus i think you know
so um yeah i mean i think it's not it's
not inconceivable that um
the
as the police become more militarized
and more violent
people will it'll start to fill over
you're going to see you know
in los angeles whenever they were
looking for uh
guy christopher dorner who had been a
former officer and
was accused of kind of going rogue and
killing people
um
you know
i believe he was los angeles police
officer but i don't think this is
actually the lapd i think it was
actually a department that in another
another town but they they shot um
there were two people that were shot um
i think there was a truck that was shot
and the man wasn't injured there was a
woman who was shot um in both cases they
thought that
it was uh dorner you know and so this
the department went on you know they
were just out in full force you know
it was a truck that you know was the i
think you know a similar
similar color not even the same color
you know and they so you know
i can see stuff like that you know
potentially happening more often you
know where people start to say well you
know this isn't just
you know you're you're busting a guy
who's selling drugs and you know
somebody gets hurt you know
this is kind of crazy and i i can you
know see maybe a backlash people say
okay we need to kind of regulate this
and so um you know
there could be a change you know i don't
think it's inconceivable um
worst case scenario i think that um
you know
you know i think that you know you'll
see
police presence essentially you know
like in uh you know
as so i think
if economic conditions worsen and
um
you know the issues of voice and divide
are not really addressed
um i think you'll see increased police
presence to where some areas will
appear to be like occupied areas where
you have kind of you know military
militarized police with assault weapons
that are you know controlling regularly
you know you're you're i mean there
already is some of that but i think that
you'll see it kind of a more widespread
you could see it in a more wide spread
you know yeah and that could become the
moon
yeah right right yeah um
you know when i think about the worst
case scenario what i think that
different developments
not just happening simultaneously but
sort of reinforcing each other
one of the things that was particularly
that's not only striking about ferguson
but it's been in the news a lot is
uh police
not allowing people to to
record what's what's going on when
they're engaging and policing activity
and that that seems particularly
sinister to me because
if there's going to be accountability um
it's it's definitely not coming through
most of the police there are some
departments that are particularly good
but they're those tend to be the ones
that have a lot of training and you know
great leadership
even the ones that are that are you know
now investing in cameras that the police
have to carry around
you can turn the cameras off you can
delete footage
so you know
sort of like the flip side of the
surveillance state idea
the citizens can be put under
surveillance and increasingly r
and that surveillance gets more and more
sophisticated as the devices get more
sophisticated as we're able to store
more data as we're able to use computer
algorithms for facial recognition voice
recognition those sorts of things
and at the same time the the citizens
are being precluded from
being able to use any of that
to to police the police
so
that makes things
much worse because you know somebody is
some police officer loses their
authority
now they can't be held accountable now
it's just their word against the
citizens word against the police and
difficult to get anything from that um
you know with the best case scenario
it would be it would be real you know
i think one of the components of that
would be
somehow
departments that that use excessive
force and by excessive i i don't mean
just in an individual way i mean sort of
like imprudent force where they
they uh
it's clearly unwarranted in the
situation would somehow be be held
responsible
um
and it might have to be you know
monetary damages you know you look at
that case down in georgia with the uh
throwing the the swat team that threw
the flashbang grenade landed in the
baby's crib the baby got 30 returns
they
they were told um there won't be any
compensation
now that seems like one of those cases
where
you know at least the federal government
could step in the doj and say you guys
really you know
you guys went too far with this
and uh something needs to something
needs to be done i don't know you know
it's difficult to think about
how exactly
that would happen particularly given the
gridlock partisan climate that we're in
right now
uh in our legislature
but you know if we if we get to be
hopeful
right that would be the best
uh for the case
you know
the court too you know to possibly hope
that the court might
um i i could see the court kind of
saying well look this is kind of you
know overboard you know it's not
um unrealistic i think to to see you
know at some point you know saying well
look you know we're gonna have to you
know but yeah without legislation it may
be difficult to do it
yeah but yeah i mean um
i think it's interesting with the uh
uh
surveillance you know you you you um
yeah i mean you make this you know
really good point that you know
um
you know increasingly we're kind of
under surveillance both by you know
nsa let's say you know but also these
police departments um
but
um police forces are kind of uh pushing
to you know
even even when it's clearly uh legal
they're they're having these cases where
you know
police officers are not allowing um
uh videotaping there's really very
little recourse that can be had
um
and you know it's interesting because
the another point i think you mentioned
we talked before um
about um
the lack of statistics
on uh police violence you know and i
think these kind of things go together
there's actually a great book by um
it's a james scott he's an anthropo
political anthropologist seeing like a
state
um
and he kind of describes basically how
you know uh
sort of state power shapes the knowledge
that's created you know he kind of goes
historical kind of account of how
formation of state kind of shape things
and i think that um
you know it's interesting that you know
this category is like non-existent the
the
nowhere in the you know huge
bureaucracies that exist does anybody
think well maybe we should figure out
you know how many times police kill you
know innocent people you know like yeah
and uh
it reminds me too i mean you know
the question of uh you know um
casualties in in iraq and afghanistan a
similar situation where you know it
seemed to be you know
you couldn't really get in any accurate
statistics the military wasn't you know
providing anything you know and and um
you know it's it's almost like this sort
of uh the sense in which you know
if if the state doesn't say this that it
exists well you know we're not really
sure you know
that it does exist you know and so i
mean i i think that would go a long way
uh developing you know even legislation
that would just demand accurate
records and statistics on police
violence you know go a long way towards
you know there is a uh impressively
there is a crowd
source project right now to produce a
database of um
all police shootings and i don't
remember how far back they want to go
and what they're doing is they're
they're getting volunteers to actually
go over
you know whatever records they can
newspaper records
anything available online to try to
piece together a composite picture
of
just how many how many shootings how
many how many discharges of weapons
there are how many of them you know
result in death how many results in
and you know this this sort of outcome
this sort of outcome
um
but it's it's you know
it's the opposite of the government it's
it's people getting together and saying
this is the sort of thing that needs to
happen who wants who wants in on it you
know
yeah and and i mean that's
unfortunately i mean it's again to me
it's just shocking that that has to be
done you know
and uh
no but i i
i really expect
that um
i expect that that you know it'll be it
would be staggering really we would be
shocked by the number of people that
were killed you know if we had you know
if this project could succeed
um
you know and it's really interesting
because you know um
uh you know
when people think about or talk about
you know okay militarized police
um
you know there is
you know there's a tendency to say well
okay we might need them for these
situations
um you know
and so there's a worry that well if we
don't have these police for this yeah
swat teams military you know we won't
have them
very extreme um or or or extremely
unlikely scenario right there's an
extremely unlikely scenario but we don't
want to we don't want to have this
situation where we don't have the
equipment we need and what they do is
they involve that they ignore you know
sort of the the type two risk you know
the
the error of you know the false positive
well what happens when we have the
equipment and we don't need it and you
know um what you have are you know
uh you know people that are killed you
know all these other kind of and these
again it's just non-existent so you know
an accurate picture of that would be
able to say well look you know um what's
the likelihood of you know most of these
towns that have this equipment facing
any of these kind of situations that
you're talking about
well you know it's you know next to
nothing
yeah well but we can we can quantify
that the number of people that are
killed you know on average by you know
forces that are participating programs
or things like that you know again they
would give a way of saying well you know
maybe we should think twice about you
know just giving this equipment to
our police forces you know so that leads
to a a different question that's not
being asked by one of the viewers and
we'll come back to viewers questions in
a moment that i wanted to
get at and it's one that comes up not
only in terms of um
militarization of police but also gun
control
the basic idea is that
when when lethal force particularly you
know in terms of uh
fully automatic weapons grenade
launchers you know
the capacity to wear gear that's going
to let you
you know tangle with people with almost
complete impunity when that's available
the the fear that a lot of people have
is um when
you know lethal equipment like that is
available it's going to get used because
it will it will put the person who's got
it in the frame framework of the you
know of seeing things you know like that
to the man who has the hammer every
every problem is a nail sort of sort of
mentality i'm not completely convinced
by that myself because i know you know
when it comes to the gun control thing i
know many people
who uh who have guns and who shoot i i
enjoy it although i don't have any guns
myself because
i just don't have any right now and i
you know having been in the military
and having you know for example you know
having
uploaded and then downloaded entire
armories
um seeing how people who you know who
know what they're doing with weapons
handle them
kind of carefully
i'm much less you know given to saying
well as soon as you put it in somebody's
hand
they're gonna they're gonna start you
know um seeing problems that can only be
solved with a gun
but i'm willing to say that
people who aren't well trained
or people who
um
and i don't just mean training in the
sense of um you know knowing how to
break the weapon down and how to
maintain it and you know how to shoot
well or when to use automatic fire as
opposed to you know single shots which
seems to be a big problem for some of
these departments
um
i i mean in terms of like how to assess
threats how to
um you know
you know essentially we're talking about
something like like phronesis prudence
you know when to do this sort of action
that there isn't a hard and fast
rulebook for what is involving deadly
force
and so my my tendency is to say for
people who are well trained giving them
you know increased
lethality is not actually going to
constitute a big problem
but for the vast majority of them who
are not well trained in that way who may
actually be you know in terms of moral
theory quite vicious
you know there could be vicious
departments where the culture is just
you know corrosive
any sort of moral compass
that's really a bad idea
and then the question is you know
how to distinguish between
the the two of those you know
yeah um
you know i mean it's an interesting
issue i mean
um especially you know again just in
terms of you know what we've been
talking about lack of statistics i mean
you know
i i find it hard to believe that there's
this kind of immense concern about the
well-being of you know people in the
danger of firearms um
you know at the same time that there's
no
there's this kind of militarization with
you know unwillingness to even you know
uh
to even uh you know
uh develop statistics that would kind of
account for you know the violence and
police force and things so yeah i mean i
think that you know the the the gun
control issue um
we do have national crime statistics for
shootings
okay yeah by criminals we don't have
them for shootings by police
i believe right yeah and so you know i
mean to push gun control i mean i think
that you know it also should be kind of
seen in terms of this issue of power and
um
you know um so
you know it's interesting um
militaries have been
uh very successful by you know using
kind of uh
uh technological advancements are very
very successful in um many of the
traditional combat or really all the
traditional kind of combat you know uh
with tanks and airplanes and things like
that but that you know
the
the area that
technology has not
um really improved uh you know the
success rate and then these kind of uh
you know urban or you know jungle kind
of mountain warfare areas and i you know
i think that um
the
the war in iraq uh
speaks to the issue of gun control and
that to see how difficult it was
essentially impossible for the u.s
military to
you know
uh modify this this population you know
kind of a heavily armed population and i
think that um much of the push behind
gun control has to do with the
recognition that you know
um this is kind of the last vestige of
power that's not controlled by the state
and so i think you're right that you
know um
you know there there there can be kind
of a
a
you know prudent use of you know weapons
and people can you know there have been
you know i think many instances of
cultures that have been you know kind of
armed and been able to kind of um you
know
teach that you know teach how to teach
you know the younger generations how to
use these things and that um
you know i you know it's definitely an
issue and a problem you know but i think
it can be done and i don't think that um
it's the kind of grounds for kind of
just a universal kind of gun control um
which i which i think it's just an issue
of kind of state power
yeah yeah
so let me um go to some questions that
have come through the google plus page
but not um through the google plus
yeah
andy hurt asked um
if we don't want police militarizing is
there ever a situation where we can
justify using military forces for
domestic humanitarian or other
non-traditional
um roles perhaps against a foreigner or
domestic
and
um i mean the national guard does does
um some things like that
not in terms of you know facing off with
with an enemy but you know in terms of
uh
natural disasters um
you know
what else uh
i mean in riots yeah the guard can get
called in for that
um
i mean important point is the guard has
been federalized too you know to a large
degree but yeah i mean i think i think
you're right yeah i mean
ideally you know if there's a need for
that well you have
a national guard that's responsive to
the governor and that's you know made up
of people who live in the state who are
able to
um you know
uh
you know and that i mean that's another
issue all together you know but you know
the question of the national guard and
where where how do they figure in and i
i think that again unfortunately they've
been kind of federalized and they're
more like
uh you know military and you know yeah
well they've been used a lot for for
deployments in iraq and afghanistan
right absolutely yeah afghanistan iraq
um
what's that go ahead
well i was gonna say in a way it it
erodes the um the regular army uh
antipathy towards guardsmen which is
probably a good thing you know because
it was
kind of jerkish behavior on our part
um when you get down to it
uh yeah yeah yeah that's true but you're
right it's like turning them from being
something that was distinctive to to the
particular states and just throwing them
in essentially as you know
replacements uh except at unit levels
into military conflicts um
i don't think a lot of people signed up
for for the guard originally thinking
they'd serve overseas unless you know we
were opposed with
like back in my day it would have been
warsaw pact you know people people in
the guard could have thought yeah we
might
we might have to face off against warsaw
pact and the soviets and they'd ship us
over to europe or something like that
but um
i don't think anybody who signed up for
the guard you know 10 years ago thought
yeah i'm going to go to afghanistan
and yet that's what happened um whereas
you know if you sign up in the regular
army
it you know if there's a war out there's
a good chance you're going to that war
so right right yeah
um
yeah
i mean one of the reasons when i got out
and they pushed you know joining the
reserves
and i knew that if i joined the you know
whatever the reserves of the national
guard i would be and now those are
distinct but you know i mean um i knew
if i joined either one i would be
back in iraq you know about i would been
in iraq probably or back in afghanistan
um
but um you know another issue though i
think with you know
um
you know the need for whether there's a
need for military i mean there can
always be situations where you know
these again these kind of extreme
situations uh you know black swan events
that we can't you know yeah you know
but um
i think that the goal should be to kind
of eliminate as much as possible the
need for that so you know
um i think that you know katrina is a
good example you know where
cities really divided there's a lot of
issues with corrupt politicians uh you
know former mayors in jail right now
um
who who was the mayor nagin
katrina um
you know there's again a lot of poverty
and and history of racism and things
like that
and um
so you know
uh the the actual the the i believe the
82nd airborne division the regular army
went into uh i mean of course with the
national guard you went into to um
new orleans it was actually reports of
navy seals being there too and uh i
actually did see you know like an hour
away i saw what looked like you know
naval special warfare
trucks and stuff you know so i was kind
of inclined to believe that it probably
was you know some other stuff so you
know um and then there's reports of
blackwater also being in uh new orleans
which
i'm not sure whether you know this is
true or not but there's been a lot of
reports um
and you know i think you know if you
think about uh new orleans and katrina
now again it's a bigger city and um
that may be part of the problem but um
there was there's a town that was
i think in missouri that was destroyed
by
a hurricane uh by tornadoes uh right
around the same time
and if you compare the difference in the
response in the way that you know
um
you know people were able to cope with
the situation you know uh it's like
night and day you know and you had
basically these this fractured city in
new orleans um everything came to a head
once
you know the hurricane hit you know you
had i mean i think some of the reports
of violence were exaggerated there were
actually a lot of reports or a lot of
instances of police violence that were
um kind of brush under for quite a while
although there were some prosecutions
eventually
but but that's kind of part of the issue
where this divide between the police and
you know and other factions are you know
in the city and um
compare that with again i wish i could
remember the name of this town but you
know
um
they were able to kind of recover really
quickly rebuild take advantage of some
of the you know programs for grants and
things like that but it was able you
know and so um i think that as much as
possible if you can
you know
have you know
uh well-functioning kind of communities
um you can you know eliminate the need
for you know a lot of this you know
whether it's fema or the federal
government you know
national guard i mean a
you know military or you know having to
come in and kind of um
you know that should be the last resort
you know the goal should be to build
brazilian communities that don't need
that kind of thing you know or rarely
need it you know um too much effort is
put on what are we gonna do whatever
you know chaos happens you know uh
regards the federal government or these
kind of things you know
not enough on you know what can
communities do to kind of cope with
things that are bound to happen you know
yeah
you know it's tempting to say that we
should
given that that sort of issue make
utilitarian arguments and say
these events that you're preparing for
are
um very unlikely
and they would be catastrophic if you
know say you know
maybe they they want to um
have a beefed up swat force so that they
can justify what if there's a there's a
you know a terrorist selling we need to
take them out but the you know the
likelihood is fairly low if if the other
you know agencies are functioning as
they ought to be
and
the cost
the the sort of sunk cost of having them
is is pretty high
if we do make these utilitarian
arguments which i think a lot of
legislators and
city planners and you know
even you know
police can can relate to fairly easily
that doesn't get us to the point though
that you were talking about the need to
create um
something beyond that resilient
communities communities where people are
progressively being better and better
incorporated into it which is and it's
always you know as you know sort of a a
constant ebb and flow it's not like you
can create a great community and then
it's a centerpiece and it's just there
and everybody's you know happy there's
always people you know falling out for
one reason or another because you know
we're human beings so we're screw-ups
we break a lot of things um so it's it's
this constant effort to sort of like
reincorporate
uh people or it does turn into to
the kind of situation that that many of
our communities are in we're atomized
we don't have a lot of interaction and
then you know the the powers that you
can run things the way that they they'd
like to
um
let me uh
pose another question this is kind of a
um
this is one that i don't actually um
see much much possibility of but gary
scott gross
he asked could a military militarized
police
force clean up wall street
and
the idea would be i think that um
you know
there's there's some
elements within the american system that
are particularly uh pernicious and could
have militarized police force you know
do anything about that i don't see them
as i don't see that as a live
possibility myself but do you see
anything to that
no i mean
unfortunately
i mean
um
you saw during occupy wall street that
um
there were officers who were
paid by
some of these banks they did security
uh they were even the report and what
the report said was they were a
distinctive uniform i think they wore a
white shirt as opposed to
whenever they were on duty with the
banks you know and so i mean i think
that you know um you know right we have
the i in most i think
probably you know
the majority vast majority of
communities or you know jurisdictions um
you know businesses can pay police
officers basically
yeah
security
and i think when you have a case like
wall street where you have lots of money
lots of political power already um you
basically have the makings of like a
private police force you know
um we can hire we can spend a lot of
money to make sure the nypd
is very loyal to us you know
um you know i so yeah i mean i think
unfortunately uh
you know um
now i mean you know it would be
interesting whether uh some of these
police surveillance techniques you know
could be used to kind of uh look at
questions of like insider trading and uh
you know uh you know all these kind of
things collusion and things like that
but i mean again uh
not you know
i don't think that that's you know
a possibility or even
something that we maybe even would want
yeah these seem to be sort of divergent
um
uh streams of
of sets of problems
um
so here's uh some other questions
here i'm actually using the q a app um
have some new ones coming up
uh so this is kind of an interesting one
this is a go go far back in history one
and there's another follow-up
to it where i don't think the person
realized that it's going to be a
follow-up to it but
so
you talk a lot about soldiers and my
question is this in germany after world
war one many soldiers went to the police
or the government after the war
um do you think this goes the same way
in the united states and how can you
control this so you know the historical
phenomenon that they're talking about
there
is in the in the weimar republic
um
a lot of uh uh ex-soldiers
you know went into
the police of the government but in part
that's because
there were a lot of i mean there's a
huge percentage of young men who had
been in the military in germany
and those were positions that they could
actually get a lot of them also joined
things like the frey corps
and and once you know civil
uh order started to break down
um soldiers were
one of the
one of the groups that veterans were one
of the groups that were a real
um
real problem
uh in in uh
post-war germany i don't think we're in
anything remotely like that because most
of the vets coming home are not joining
the police or the government they're
actually getting
fairly you know poor treatment by the
government uh we just talked about the
va and there's constant scandals
appearing you know
weekly about
what what actually happens to our combat
soldiers when they come home
um
a lot of them are coming home
to
places where you know there's already a
police department
and they're the ones that are seen like
we said earlier
uh as as a threat i don't think that
we're in any danger of
having something like a
viable fry core
movement on the right where disgruntled
um
you know iraq and afghanistan
veterans would be joining in on mosques
to fight you know some some particular
enemy here in the united states
um although you know we have these these
pretty small
extremist groups on on the right
and they do draw some veterans but they
also draw a lot of
wannabes i think
people who have no military experience
and just you know like biv whacking
that sort of thing what's what's your
take on on that do you see a real danger
there
no i think you're right i mean i think
that um you know the military makes up a
very small percentage of the total
population and
you know um i don't think it's anywhere
um
i would guess you know that the size of
you know um
the ratio was much greater and and obama
republic you know that and you know back
then i mean there were huge amounts of
people that are joining the military and
um
and i mean the other thing is that you
know
for instance in ferguson um
you know i mean you did see a lot of
outcry from veterans to say well look
this is not actually
it's not very this is not legitimate you
know um and part of that was because the
military um
went through a kind of uh
sort of revolution really under petraeus
where he brought in uh he brought in a
guy david kilcullen who was a
counter his counter insurgency expert
and you know they were successful for a
time and they they really used um
till cullen it was a former
australian army officer and was an
anthropologist to ph.d anthropology and
um you know kind of specialized in
looking at these conflicts really in
terms of
the underlying politics viewing them in
the political light and uh that's really
what the military sought to do in iraq
to really understand
the sunni
shia uh issues and then also the
relationship between al qaeda
sunni and the sunnis and she you know
how all this kind of worked out and
basically figure out a way to
reinforce the community how could a
military
in a real sense you know in terms of
like subsidiarity you know how can the
military kind of reinforce
these local communities and kind of help
them to kick out al qaeda which is what
happened in the uh
they call it the uh the
sunni awakening i think is what they
call it in iraq so i think a lot of
military personnel
uh who are involved in this really
understand that
um this type of you know confrontational
policing
is counter-productive you know for all
yeah
i'm surprised
that nobody um somebody must have done
this somewhere but there's there's a
strong analogy between what actually
worked in iraq when things worked in
iraq and what community policing looks
like
absolutely yeah
so let's let's take another uh question
which is the
i think along these sort of lines and
i've i've got my my views on how this
could fit in and but we'll i'll let you
answer first because i've been jumping
in quite a lot so it's um
what's your opinion about global fascism
and national socialism
do you see that as applying here at all
or
i mean i do i think that um i you know
i'm a i'm a big fan of uh sheldon wohlin
i don't know if you're familiar with
political political theorists um yeah
yeah big big hobbs scholar
uh uh yeah tocqueville also you know um
he just really happens by chokeville and
he um
yeah i mean he's got you know kind of
tries to kind of reinvigorate uh
uh
chucksville's idea it's the uh
tip of my mind now about
basically about uh
individualism and bureaucracy i can't
remember the term that toggle has but
the way roland calls it is managed
democracy and he's kind of seeing kind
of increased corporate power um
influencing
political structures and um
you know
um
sort of you know
provoking this kind of militarization
where you have increased polarization so
i think that yeah underlying a lot of
these issues
um
underlying a lot of these issues are the
uh
is the uh
increased inequality
and um
you know uh
the
you know neoliberalism really that's
been kind of dominant for the past 30
years or so i mean i think that um
insofar as kind of economic issues are
polarizing it tends to polarize others
and that you know people with money have
more power are able to kind of uh
basically use the fleet to kind of
well anyway i think those are should
underline it maybe need to be spelled
out a little bit more exactly but you
know
for me i take a different um view
towards it basically because of the the
terminology that's that's used i have i
totally agree that that this has been
you know several decades of
neoliberalism
and that globalism is more or less
looked like that
and it's had terrible effects here in
the states
and i think that there are a lot of
oppressive
structures that that come with that
many of which do involve exploitation
and violence i don't see them as as
connected with fascism in any
rigorous sense of the term and i think
that fascism is one of those terms
that has been thrown out by by people in
very loose ways and when that when
people do that it just loses any any
sort of meaning it just becomes i don't
like what you're doing you're a nazi
you're a fascist you're you're this and
that and i i want to hold out for
actually
you know using the term in a more uh
rigorous way same thing with national
socialists who's different than fascists
um
because
i think that to be able to diagnose it
when it's actually happening and to
distinguish other structures uh power
other types of totalitarianism
or
uh other other oppressive structures
remember they're happening
um
foucault had this idea of microfascism
that some people have picked up on but
that basically comes down to
you know using power in such a way as to
sort of corral people in it's about
liking having power over people and i
think that that goes on but that's not
something particularly connected with
fascism and such that we can see this in
you know classical
moral and political theory augustine
talks about the libido dominenti you
know the drive to to dominate other
people to control them
and
so what i would say in this case is what
we're looking at with these police
forces
is not something that's a
manifestation of fascism let alone you
know some world fascism um
far-right parties are there there's some
out there and they're not doing
particularly great over the last you
know half century
um
you know where we see stuff like this
really becoming more and more
looking like classical fascism where
you've got mobilization of the masses
palenogenesis you know myth um
all these sort of things that go into
what we call the fascist minimum in
fascist studies
would be some would be you know places
more like
like contemporary russia you know the
discourse about the decadence of the
west
um so i don't see that as a particularly
helpful
category for figuring out
what's going on in america which means
that we ought to be looking for
other categories to describe what the
hell's going on here because because
clearly we do have some some deep
problems and clearly there are
similarities between the police force
and ferguson
and you know what what happens in
atlanta and what happens over here so we
want we want
better
descriptors than
using old terms that
you know sound good make us feel good
when we call a cop of fascist but don't
actually provide any any illumination
yeah i mean i think you're definitely
right
in a sense that there's a there's a big
difference i mean i i suppose i just
think in terms of um
uh you know corporate kind of power and
its influence in the state but i mean i
think that yeah i mean you know there's
definitely not you know i don't think
kind of over racial motivation a lot you
know a lot of these elements that you're
talking about yeah i mean are not
factors in the situation
yeah i mean race
operated a very different way in
national socialism than it does in in
this sort of you know militarized
policing stuff
um
you know
there there is the similarities that
there were racial divides and there were
you know people
who had power and people who didn't have
power and those who had power were
oppressing those who didn't have it
um but but the differences are so vast
that i don't i don't know
that's useful here
um again it's it's stuff that makes
people feel good to say
but um
it doesn't um get us other than having
that nice feel good for a minute doesn't
get us anything let's look at a few of
the other
um
leandra lima has another question do you
think
we still have a chance to somehow unite
in some sort of national backlash
backlash i'm guessing about militarized
policing
i mean we we've talked a little bit
about this before i yeah i do i think
that
i think it's very possible that um
you know uh
if for instance if there's a
high-profile case where
someone is killed and it's kind of you
know it's possible that congress will
say look we need to kind of regulate the
store you know i mean
i don't think it's inconceivable that
you know
that this will kind of
uh wayne you know i mean uh you know
or you know the
of the course as we said you know um i
don't think it's a situation where it's
kind of impossible to
at least make some significant changes
you know
yeah it looks like it's gonna make a
couple different things happening too
like when uh
something happen in terms of the
legislature
you know um and something is going to
have to happen in terms of
sort of you know consciousness
raising on the part of ordinary people
so it's not just that community they're
doing a march and you know their problem
over there but the rest of us saying
what the hell is going on here this this
is not this is no longer tolerable
this is wrong
um
and then having those things come
together
and staining it that seems you know
um
quite difficult
um so
it's more of a challenge at this point
than some sort of blueprint
that's probably a fitting place for us
to bring these
discussions and reflections about
militarized policing to a close since
these sessions last an hour and a half
i'd like to thank caleb for coming on
again particularly at short notice
uh it's been a very
enjoyable discussion and i'll let you
have the last word and bring us out
um yeah well i'd like to say the same
thing i um absolutely uh
absolutely enjoyed the discussion and
you know glad to come back on i think i
mentioned i'm kind of working on a uh
conference cloakland presentation on on
this topic and so um
i wanted to close actually with a um
uh
just a quote from uh
raymond goice
the book of philosophy and real politics
it really
speaks to um
speaks to this issue you know and he
says
um
he says that
uh you know we need to kind of look to
uh to all people lenin's formula who
whom
you know and uh we should think about um
so i'll just
he says
lenin defines politics with
characteristic clarity and pipiness when
he says that is concerned with the
question that keeps recurring in our
political life who whom
what this means in the first instance
is that the impersonalized statements
one might be inclined to make about
human society
generally require if they are to be
politically informative elaborations
into statements about particular
concrete people doing things to other
people
and i think that you know that's kind of
the issue that we need to kind of think
about you know
um what does this actually mean in kind
of day-to-day life you know and and for
the actual people that are involved
telling their stories letting those
people tell their stories that's kind of
a way to kind of um
you know again make hopefully make kind
of incremental kind of improvements you
know
all right well thanks to all of our
viewers and uh we'll be continuing these
i'm sure caleb will
uh be happy to come on for some other
ones uh down the line we're trying to do
these monthly so
have a good night everyone and uh thanks
again caleb
thanks everybody